もう一歩だらもうちょっとバナー感を強くすると差分めちゃくちゃ美味しいと思います
をしながら俺がしょーった時とあるゲームが学校中で流行ったことがあったんだよ今の
方も知らないかもしれないんですけどこちらベイブレードっていう
米語漫画賞か動いてなった奴が流行ったんですよ俺の時代の時に流行ったものがある
じゃんベイベーという業
ポスティングとか色々あるんですけど俺の世代の人たちがみんな社会人になってね働き
出して金がたくさんあるんでそこの高ターゲッ
いやこれはまりはない方がいいなぁなんでもありませんペットなんか最近ねべネイと
復活したということで僕は姉部でめちゃくちゃ強かったんですよお店の大回転はで
ロックいいとばになったこともあった
僕の使いたがる音でしたねいう話をしてもその場ばない人がいるんで
レズレールデートってね米熊で戦うのがすごい昔流行ったんですベル red
burst ってちょっと新しいのようになりました
スプリンガースプレッドフュージョンっていう女性は館内最近が米日だということだね
これは米土間を戦わせるやつがあるんですよ
いやあもうね俺よねこれでもう
はなんか発売で決定した時から買おうと思ってたんだやもう俺ぐらいの世代の人渡部
みんなベーベルだってたブラウンストームぐらいからお店で買えなかったですよ
今で妖怪ウォッチみたいなプっしょんちょベイブレード知らない人いるー
ベイブレード知らないといったらちょっと上か悲しいんだけど昔はねみんな
ベイブレードしてたんですよ
な造りからがバラバラってあるんですけどティトに作っ
みましょうワインダー奥を入れてこうですこれで3通は豪州とってったらベイブレード
じゃーん
undo わー
やったことがないとれた道と令を敷いてよ本当に面白いから多摩懐かしいねえべレイド
シール貼れてめんどくさかった覚えがあるわ
シールを貼るという作業を乗り越えて初めて楽しくってくださいめんどくさ
めんどくさできたできた
いやーきついところにシールめんどくさかったベッドどうぞ同同同同
これでいいのをはい行きました
なんか怖いんだけど大丈夫なのかなこれ豪州
[音楽]
大
oo
おお懐かしいあれ日もあったこういう感じなんせますで
女懐かしいんだけどはなんか青春だなぁ
これがやってもね戦えないんですよちょっとスタジアムも買ったんでベルデとしたじゃ
ないと始まったいところがあるんで
懐かしい何ツイコレだ音色いるこれは飛んでいかないようにするってこと
[音楽]
大
こういう感じでメールを合わせて戦うんですよよしできたぞというこちらの2つですね
別途何度か何正しいジョンとばびてぃなんとかなんとか2つなベイブルーとなって僕は
もう一人で戦いますよ
it のベイブレードスターズあるんで戦わせてみましょうねえツイートああああああ
デー
痛い時ん
ねえませんを繋いじゃっ落ちてねっ
ちゃうなんてこんなことである
これからよした
さあどうぞ
はいどうぞ8 ae
tee
ええええええええわー
俺だぁああ
ブーブーこの後あー止まるか
リングから出るか挙げる可能カチュアのパターンが3つあるらしいですウードゥー
ん
voodoo
誰かとやりたいな
[音楽]
war
ます
しています